et maintenant un regard spécial sur les coulisses
de John Carter les gens voulaient quelque chose
qui les emmènerait dans un autre endroit
ça va certainement le faire où suis-
je
tu te bats pour nous j'ai adoré l'histoire nous
voulions voir ce monde dans ces
personnages sur  l'écran la portée est
crédible je me promène sur des échasses dans
cet environnement la fin de la journée
tu ne penses pas qu'il était prêt
à tomber tu penses juste que c'est le
personnage quand je t'ai vu je croyais que
c'était le signe  c'est assez incroyable, je
comprends que j'ai créé une salle tellement incroyable
que c'est fou,
voyez de quoi il est capable de
vous